Good afternoon, Karen.
Hello, how are you?
Doing good, how about you?
I'm doing well.
Good, good to hear.
Alexis is going to join.
I believe he is.
He did just send a message to one of our customers, though, so...
Yeah, no problem. Give a few minutes. How's everything going?
It's going well, and you?
Yeah, pretty busy, a lot of things around, so...
I hear you're waiting for monsoon season.
Yeah, hopefully end of this end of June, so onward from next month. The other weather is pretty pleasant nowadays.
How's everything going on business side?
But...
I was wondering, do all of you take a cab to and from work?
Yeah, 80, 90% of the employee, because what we do here, right? We provide them a cab facility where we, because he has a night shift, right? So we'll make sure that the people are fully secure. So we drop their location, we pick from their exact location. So just kind of safety point of view. There's no issue traveling in the night, but yeah.
Ohh.
With their female employees, you know, we still want to make sure that everyone is is on home on time.
Okay.
and reach office on time.
That's nice.
And of course, cost effective is because if you, for example, if I'm coming my own, maybe I have spent $100, but if I avail the company cab, probably I'll pay only 40 bucks. So that's cost difference as well. We charge very minimum amount, maybe 30, 40% of what.
Ohh.
The actual charges are if they come their on.
Same goes for the food as well. So we have our own restaurant in the inside the building where we offer the food like if it is a lunch, dinner, breakfast and snacks is 24 by 7. So they can pay very minimal amount and they can have the dinner lunch if anyone is not bringing their.
you know, lunchbox or dinner from home.
Ohh.
Hi.
I usually bring my lunch.
Yeah, see, I also don't eat outside, so I'll bring my old diet foods and everything.
Oh, there he is.
There we go.
I...
How are you doing, guys?
Ohh, good, good.
Good to see you.
See, as well.
I, uh, um...
So, how are you doing this week?
Yeah.
My weekend is and weekdays is pretty.
Right, so a lot of things going around project, another few migration project were in queue, so working on those. So, I think before I probably Amit is going to join, but I think I just wanna share a few things with you before Amit jump into that. So, probably you already get the idea that Anim is right, so...
Mhm.
The.
He's working pretty good, but like few gap that we noticed, right? So I think the other proposal that you probably only have the other for the other person, so that you get that resume. So I think that's my personal suggestion before I'm gonna jump into the call. He's a pretty good and he's already working on the SME.
Mmh.
Well, are you saying I could swap, I can swap the people or what? Yeah.
Yeah, that's what my recommendation. So, like, you probably won't believe is he's, I think, the most senior entainer guy in IT ware design, mostly 78 year of experience in IT ware design, and I think, you know, Vim, he's expert and he's already working with an SME role on the client side.
Mm.
Mhm.
So I think you'll be going to perfect fit. So whatever may be the small gap that we have, but I again, that's my again, yeah.
Okay.
Yeah, so, so that's the that's the question is whether I can swap and then I don't know what you're going to do with Anamesh if you swap them out as you have it.
He probably gonna align to a different partner immediately, so it's not that he probably have to wait or get, yeah, the same way, yeah, it's not that if he's out from if he mighty, then he has to wait for, yeah.
Okay, alright.
Okay.
That's all Amit and the other leadership here. Yeah, okay, here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Sounds good. Thank you.
Amit.
I Amit.
Aleks, hi Karen, sorry.
Hello.
I also added an email account for you, Aman, so you can jump on some calls. I sent you a password, so you could jump on, you know, a couple of, you know, prospect or meetings, that type of thing.
So, yeah, and Amit, we were just talking about, how do you say his name? Safe? Safe?
Yeah.
Set, set, Seth.
Deaf, yep, yep, yep.
And you know, possibly swapping, swapping out on a mesh out for soft Amit.
Yeah, I mean, of course it depends, right? I mean, if you need an extra head in the team, then of course you can add. Or if it is swapping out, if that is also an option that you want to go for, then of course me and Ron can discuss. It completely depends, right? So, yeah.
Yeah, I mean, there is that, you know, yeah. Okay, well, you guys can discuss that internally. I think a swap, I mean, is financially more feasible at this time, but
Kam.
I also looked at your schedule for 3.30 A.m.
Mhm.
Yeah, which is, you know, um...
You know, instead of the, you wanted the half hour shift change for Vincent and Animesh to be starting at those particular times. So we can do that. The half hour, you wanted them to start 1/2 hour earlier than I proposed.
Yeah, I wonder if you can bring it up on screen. So, Alex, just one more thing before we get to the shift schedule. Do you have any availability today to speak to Seth or tomorrow? Because you may have seen Ron's email, right? He's actively getting considered for other opportunities also. So.
Yeah.
I didn't want you to lose that object. See if you have some availability probably today or tomorrow first thing.
K.
Yeah, I didn't, I didn't see that.
See about about today.
Just one more thing, Alex, for the purpose of transparency. Saf, of course, if you understand, right, he's an SME, which means that on a salary point of view, he will be on slightly higher bracket as compared to an image. So that's something that we may want to consider as well.
Yeah, um...
Yeah, understood. We can review that when we receive.
The quote, I mean, I think I think the trouble is, I hired on a match as a level 3 engineer in the 1st place, and he's not, you know, he's not quite there, you know, but we'll see, we'll see what happens on the proposal if we go through an interview with with with staff.
Mhm.
F.
Yep.
So I am available today after 3 o'clock anytime.
Three o'clock, 4 o'clock might be a little bit better, but yeah, no, you know what, 3 o'clock is fine. Three, 330 or 4 o'clock today, Eastern Time. Okay.
Okay, okay. Let me, okay. Let me quickly check with my team and get back. Okay.
Yeah.
Okay, sounds good.
All right, and then the shifts shift change for January 29th depend, obviously, if Anamesh is still here, that's fine. If he's not, then we'll make a different adjustment for that. But right now he comes at 2 A.m. Eastern, so we want to switch him to 330 A.m. Eastern to figure.
cab schedule. And then Vincent was going to be 10 A.m. but we'll start them at 930 A.m. to fit the cab schedule as well.
Yep.
Yeah, somewhere I think somebody's aligned, so...
Is good on that, uh, the shift to one hour early.
Yeah, and then summer summarize 7 A.m. one hour earlier, yeah.
Yeah.
Sorry.
So, yeah, I probably, I'll check first. Maybe, yeah, we know already that every day we connect, right? But still, I want to hear from your side how everything going, you know, individually as a team, and I know we have few to-dos and everything, so, but yeah, just gonna hear from your side, how are you planning?
Support that you think need from our side.
Yeah, so I think we're heading, you know, we're continuing to get better. I believe, like I said, on this morning, at 12:00, I had a call with Amit.
You know, we're pretty happy with the direction things are going.
You know, we did speak a little bit about those, you know, animus challenges, right? Um, even this either earlier today.
Yep.
And, you know, in fact, in fact, while I was between the first call and 2nd call today,
I was actually, you know, I wanted to ask more directly, you know, regarding the possibility of a swap if, you know, Amit, regarding...
on a mesh and the and staff.
Saf, Saf, I can't.
Yeah.
if that was a possibility or not. But again, you know, that's something you can, you know, put in the quote. I can do the interview and then you guys can figure that out, even though, you know, yeah, so we'll figure that out.
You know, we're pretty good, I think.
You know, we're only two weeks into the team with Summer on board, so it's only two weeks. You know, we have a lot of, I have work to do, we all have work to do to get everything squared away. But we're heading in the right direction. I have a really hard time, you know, like I said, I actually had a very positive review this morning with these guys overall.
You know, with Amit and and Ronald on the call.
Yep.
Definitely feeling like or or or getting somewhere.
I have to be patient. I talked to the team this morning, to our team, you know, with everybody on the call.
you know, everyone on the IT by design, like Animesh, Sameer, Shivani, and Vincent. I said, you know, we got to be patient, put one foot in front of the other and try to get to where we need to go. There's a lot of work to do. But, you know, I really feel like we've come a long way with the team where we are today. How is
Is Anamesh unhappy? I want to know if he's unhappy or how's he feeling? Is he okay?
He's pretty good. I had a word with him, right? So yeah, of course, he really don't want to leave the way, by the way you handling team and everything, the type of work that he's getting. So he's pre-aligned, right? But again, end of that is a business requirement, right? So we're here to fulfill those requirements, and if you are lacking somewhere, and you know.
Yeah.
giving different resource, getting, you know, better outcome, right? So that's what our main goal is.
I guess, you know, I like I said earlier today, I said I like Animesh as his soft skills. I like a lot of his skills. I think his experience just isn't there, you know, and he could work under potentially soft and, you know, summer, for example, if I have the bandwidth to...
To maintain the effectively the payroll, and or you know that we do want to be a building team as well, so, or you know, if if Anamesh is something someone that can develop right, and that benefits both sides, like you guys as well as us, as well as Anamesh, right? Like, he's a happy person in his role.
Kip.
when he's happy to be on the team and he sees the growth, then, you know, then that could be a nice complementary combination of things. Because it can also be very helpful for Summer and Soft to have somebody like on a mesh around as well to
Yeah.
And then it gives him the opportunity to grow on the team as well. And he's somebody that would be, I think, loyal. He's got a good loyal, long-term sort of outlook, I think Animesh does. Just like Sameer, Sameer, Amit, you were saying? Yeah.
It does.
No, all I'm saying is Animesh has the right attitude. I've seen him happily working, right? I mean, you can read from the face that he's not annoyed or he's not. There is not any anxiousness that I see on his face, right? He's pretty comfortable enjoying work. I see Sameer and him too.
Yeah.
Right.
talking a lot, which is a green flag to be honest, because these guys are interacting with each other, asking each other. I see Summer stepping up quite a few times, right, and helping him too. So that's a good team, good team coordination, so which is a great thing.
Mm.
Mm mhm.
That's a good thing, yeah.
And Alex, yeah, if you, once you've spoken to Seth, then I'm trying to coordinate on chat as we speak. It's entirely your choice. If you think that, you know, Seth could be an addition to the team, rather a replacement, of course, he can go down that path as well. I think based on.
Mhm.
Yeah, I'm thinking, you know, my initial thought was addition and this is a good conversation to have. Okay, so let's go ahead. I didn't mean to interrupt.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, no, so although I was trying to say that, you know, it's what we've seen in the MSP industry, right? That is very difficult to find the people with progressive nature, right? I mean, because once you get it, these are the people who settle into the system and continue to grow over the time. It is the mindset that matters the most.
What we currently have is some excellent resource with a great mindset. If you like Seth, for some reason, I feel that 99% I'm confident that you like him because I think we have a fair understanding of your ask also. So yeah, he will be an amazing addition. And of course, how we see Animesh working.
Mhm.
in the team and how he's speaking up, right, he can continue to grow. And of course, we have Aman there who can be the guiding force for them on the ground. And with the right amount of support, right, they can help each other and continue to grow. I don't see that as a challenge until unless, you know, you have financial constraints.
Yeah, yeah, I think I think that you know, if if Saf is a higher level, you know, engineer, he'll be able to take, he'll be able to focus like I have tried to get Animesh to focus on certain outcomes, where whereas you know, unfortunately, Animesh doesn't have that experience to to do all of that.
Yeah.
Mm.
Right? So, you know, to be able to take somebody like Saf and put them in to drive some of those outcomes, you know, on the infrastructure and backup and disaster recovery configurations and performance, you know, improvements, dashboard configurations, you know, all of the proper monitoring and management tools, as well as the alerting, etc.
Yeah.
Mm.
And then somebody like Automesh can be underneath that and be able to respond to the alerts and things like that on a day-to-day basis. All right, does that sort of make sense?
Yep.
Mhm.
Yeah, no, no.
It does, it does, certainly does.
Vaid.
What do you think, Aman? Does that sound pretty good to you?
Yeah, actually, I'm fully aligned with, so I think the better we have the layer one, layer two, layer three, so I think Saf is going to fill the layer 4th gap, and that we have now. Somebody's on 3rd, Saf is on top of all four of the that people that have now. Shivani owns a layer one, then Vincent, of course, so the complete.
Yeah.
Okay, yeah.
To complete a good text, yeah, that's right.
The complete stock, yeah, yeah, yeah, no, I think that's that sounds really exciting. So, I think that that might, you know, I have a meet in that soft, but you're already telling me, I mean, unless there's something, you know, I mean, you're already telling, I don't, I almost won't even, I might not even need to interview him, right?
No, I'll let you decide.
You know what I mean, but...
No, you do. Please do. Please do. I think this is where I will personally feel confident, else this will get overwhelming for me. So yeah, I'll let you interview. Alex, I'll go on hold for a quick 30 seconds, speak to the bench team so that they can send the invite for you.
Uh...
Ha ha ha.
Sure.
Okay, okay.
Um, I'm getting a sent for you said three anytime after three.
Yeah, same time after three.
Okay, so I'm putting it for 3 or 3.30. I'll be right back with the confirmation.
As far, okay, no problem, no problem.
Okay, cool.
Oh.
As far as the time frame is concerned, though, I didn't, you know, when he would come on board, right? Would it be, you know, two weeks, would it be 30 days? Like, is the question. Do we have an idea?
I think he can be onboarded as soon as possible. Probably not going to take time. The reason why I asked you personally, because I know this is a pretty good resource. So, you know, again, I'm looking my growth, my looking APMIT growth, because if I get the person like him in the part, right, everything I'm looking in the.
Mhm.
Future point of view now, so if someone else pick him right, and if I get because probably you already know the business model that we follow different TLR here, right? Manager here, so under us work different twenty-thirty people, different client side, so I know which person is good in what technology and who can help us, who can fit in in our role.
whether getting someone because he's working for last I think six or seven year in the ITBD by design itself and all experience that has L3 plus and SME role. So when he joined and he worked all in the infra level where creating infra from the scratch, managing that everything you know.
Mhm.
Mm.
Yeah, yeah, so that's good. I didn't, yeah, I didn't even, it'll be curious to see how him and Sameer work together and obviously it allows me to, again, truly, fully delegate all this stuff and get it off my plate and grow, really, it's all about scale.
Just similar.
Exactly, that's right. We both has worked with me for many projects, and for whenever we get any other project, like, so they were part of most of the project where I involved them, whether it's a migration, backup, Intune, any project that I had, you know, they were always the part of those projects.
You know the scale, the scale.
Mhm.
So that's why I know personally them as well, the way they work.
So, when you say that, so, so when they worked for an MSP, how could they be on a project for a different MSP when they are working for an MSP?
Going into overseas, yeah.
So prior to when they don't have, for example, someone we offered from the client, right? So it'll take like few days, week to them to align to the interview, then the onboarding process, everything. So next maybe 15, 20 days a month, they're on bench, right? They're not doing anything but just kind of interviewing and giving interview.
and going through the selection process. So during that time, I utilize them to just be in a part of this project and help me on to complete that. But yeah, but if they are already aligned with the any Partner on the end, then they're going to focus on that side only.
Right.
I think this could also be good because I think Vincent might be a little overwhelmed regarding some of the security stuff that I'm asking him to do. Like, so I think that I got to figure out how, how, well, for that matter, I can, you know, how I utilize summer, summer and and and soft to.
Yeah.
try to compliment and, you know, maybe even support Vincent a little bit. I think Vincent should be should be okay. He just would would would benefit from a little bit more mentorship, I think, from somebody who's more senior when it comes to when I really start to push down, you know, and say, hey, we got to get these things completely done. I also plan on building, you know, I really think the best thing I can do
Yeah, that.
is build 2 sort of baseline tenants, like our baseline customers, so fake companies, like 2 fake companies with full-blown infrastructure, so that I can see, yeah, so they can all see what, number one, what it needs to look like, so we can deploy full.
Yeah.
the full product across the board without impacting a customer network, right? And then they can test and try and make sure it's good. And then, and then it's like practice, you know, they get to practice that and then go into our customers' environments, especially when it comes to our security stack, which is our biggest issue, right? Aside from backup, of course, which I thought was going to be way easier.
But yeah, yeah, the backup situation. So when that gets, that's all, that's that, that can be, yeah, much improved and solved, but the cybersecurity stack is a big part of it. I'll have to look over his interview or his resume and then.
I know.
Just wait to hear from Amit for the interview.
No, no, yeah, that sounds like a plan. I think from service delivery point of view, the only thing I think we already discussed, I think if we have any better plan or maybe you want to discuss another time to see, like they are doing a lot of things, right? I know they're working on ticket, different project, but I think there is no mechanism where...
how we evaluate that, whatever they are doing, is they are able to complete those. So there's no way to track their activities and anything. I mean, buy the ticket, I can go check, do their board review, but it is not giving me a centralized visibility that where, who person, where we stand, what they're doing, whatever the task is given to them, are they able to complete on.
Yeah.
those on time, where they are lacking, what are the area of improvement. So I'm just trying to figure out a way to just work with you to kind of plan something for each individually. So they are clear what their role responsibility is going to be and how we're going to measure. Because there's no measurement, of course, they're not going to, they're coming to office, what I observed.
If they get 10 ticket, they're gonna work on 10 ticket, they're gonna work 15, they're gonna work 5, but is those 10 is handled on time is whatever we are looking for at the delivering that is the customer is satisfied, whatever they are performing, you know, so kind of all overview I'm gonna see a centralized way to monitor them, you know.
So if you have any plan, then yeah, we definitely can discuss and align them.
Yeah.
Well, I think part of my challenge right now is, right now for anything, is the amount of time I have. Especially now, again, here we are with another person that we're about to hire. So the hiring and onboarding process takes time. And right before I hired Summer, I hired
Right.
Vanessa, even though she's not working currently at the moment, but like if I'm hiring somebody every week and onboarding, there's just constant changes taking place. And the way that, yeah, how to help you measure, one of the things, how to help us all measure, how to help us make sure everybody understands their roles and responsibilities.
Yeah.
You know, I can share a lot of like, I mean, I could give you probably all my slide decks that I have on a weekly meeting basis because alignment is provided, I think, in a lot of ways, I do more than other MSPs from a standpoint of that, you know, that weekly meeting alone is probably.
more than what most MSPs do from a direct interaction standpoint with the team to give them the set of instructions and direction to go. You know, you know, I mean, I mean, Sameer immediately noticed, I think, a certain level of activity for me that he wasn't even used to seeing.
That is all MSP in terms of, you know, some technical things, and so that was good for the first couple of days, but...
You know, I know that you wanted that ConnectWise log in.
This is the way I'm just add the web, just, you know, sorry to interrupt here. So only two thing I'm capturing as of now, right, which is again a manually processes, like what is their billable hours they're living out of eight, how many hours they're delivering, how many ticket they worked, how many ticket they are closing. So that's three thing visually that I have.
You know, go ahead.
You know, as of now, probably I can give you a quick overview just for my own purpose. I'm...
Yeah.
I know, but it's any time I'll look at this, it's misleading, right? Because first and foremost, oh, this is, okay, this is, is this our company, APM? How did you get this? Oh.
Oh, this is just the number, yeah, so, uh, for example, yeah.
Yeah, APM. So how did you, did I, I don't know, I didn't give you a login, did I? How did you get the data?
No, no, it's not login, just manually numbers. So, what I do, I review the tickets, what all they're doing, like, for example, or Vincent worked, like, let's take example of Vincent, right, for yesterday time sheet, so he delivered 6.7 hour.
Okay.
Mhm.
As per his time sheet, is in ConnectWise. So just the number I captured, 6.7 hour. Then how many tickets that he worked, how many he works on 12 ticket, he closed 4. So that's kind of tracking the data daily. So if I need to see, like in June month, we have 4 engineers.
Mm-hmm.
Mhm.
So he delivers 62 hours as of now, right? Non-billable activity, which is include your meetings, any other connect that you have. And what is a billable percent is 65, non-billable 12. And so overall, the utilization of 177.5. So any.
I mean, worked 109 ticket, closed 53 ticket. So again, these are manually numbered, right? So, but if I need to know that what all he had done in the ticket is handle on time, yeah.
Yeah.
Deepak.
Well, here's, I'm gonna, I gotta interrupt you for a second. The problem with these dashboards, okay, and of course, look, I mean, I know people need to measure certain things, but like, okay, Karen's on the call right now. So for many, many years, we actually used BrightGauge. We tried to use BrightGauge a few months ago when we first started with Shivani and Thomas.
Shukla.
And, you know, the trouble with that is I just fired somebody that was closing 50 tickets a week, right? And had 40, you know, 40 hours exactly of utilization every week. Okay. He lost his job. Okay. You understand what I mean? So
But we, yeah, well, we need, we need quality work, yeah.
So, so the trouble is, you, you know, when you measure something, is that really the reason that they work for me, right? Or, you know, am I just as happy if, you know, you know, you know, like, for example, you know, and Karen can speak to this, Karen knows this, she's dealing with this every day because now she's more active.
Yep.
in the service board, but she's responding to tickets before the texts are responding to tickets, right? So she's seeing things. Why is she seeing things? And then having to, you know, tell the team, hey, customer responded to the ticket, hasn't heard back yet. Hey, customer hasn't, you know, so why, and I make sure these, all the texts.
have two or three screens, right? So the reason they have three screens is so they can see everything. You can't say, oh, I didn't see it, right? So you could see, you need to be able to see your email, you need to have your calendar up to date, you need to update tickets on time, right? These are the things I stress with you all the time. You know, if you, if we look at, you know,
Yep.
you know, ticket, that's what I'm concerned about. First, more so then how many tickets did you close? Because there could be any ticket that can take a long time. Some tickets are more complicated, right? So it's not about the quantity, it's about the quality. The quality. So to me about qualitative, so how do you qualitatively?
Yeah.
The quality, that's right.
When I have a customer that reports an issue, are we communicating with them? Right? How is the communication going? Are we dropping the ball? Is our customer service where it needs to be? And I consider that a standard, not an extra. It's like you need to, as a tech engineer.
make sure you are updating the tickets. The ticket is the area where the source of truth is. So even Summer, right? If Summer is working on something and he sends me a Team message and says it's done, but the ticket's not done, and you know, there's no update in the ticket and his time entry is not in there, it's worse.
And yeah.
Right, he needs to do that first, and then he can send me maybe a Teams message if he wants. Teams message is fine, but it's the ticket that needs to be accurate, right?
Yeah, that's exactly my point is to how we find, because those gap in a way that they are doing things on time or not. So that's what the only thing I was looking to track these all, because of course you cannot, yeah, go ahead and check in digital ticket.
Yeah, and and you, you know, and I under and and and you know, we can tracking that on time. So, for example, Shivani was it was Monday, customer reported a problem.
What day is it? Yeah, it's Wednesday, so it was Monday. Customer asked for something at 9:17 A.m. OK, again, we don't have a lot of tickets. Let's be clear: the the the the the tickets that require reactive support aren't like usually like 2 to 4 tickets a day, right? Those are and now we're adding more tickets from the other side.
That's right.
which I'm giving to Animesh and Sameer as well. But the tickets that come in that I'm most concerned about is when a customer has a complaint. Like, that's extremely important. You know, if they can't do something, that we're responding to those tickets. So customer, 9, 17 A.m. ticket comes in and
It was it showed in progress at 3 P.m. in the afternoon and then there was no real updates on the customer facing side of the ticket with no clarity. Shivani was on it and then I messaged Shivani and I say, hey, what's going on with this? She says, oh, it's escalated. Vince is working on it.
And I'm like, well, it doesn't show it's escalated. The ticket status wasn't updated to escalated. The year time wasn't entered. The customer hasn't been updated on a customer spacing note. These are all things I've talked about over and over in all of our PowerPoint presentations, all of our weekly meetings. I've repeated them and especially repeated them today. And I even sent out a new slide deck with all that information, which
I will share with you. I can share with you right now. In fact, we could do that right now. I could share my screen and show you the kinds of things we review weekly. So, you know, I think that I think the gap of a couple of things is that...
You know, this is why you're out of the loop when you don't need to be out of the loop, right? I'm all about keeping you in the loop. But I don't put, I don't make you attend our meetings or anything like that. And then we, again, we need to find ways for you to measure this stuff.
Yep.
Exactly.
and for us to work together. I think I could share this little deck with you. Amit, what are we looking at?
But it does.
Yeah, so just a quick thing I wanted to check. He finishes early today, right? I mean, his shift ends at 3.30. So, and the conversation may go a little further, right? Not necessarily that we want to limit the conversation to half an hour. Any possibility of speaking to him early morning tomorrow?
Uh-huh.
Aleks.
Oh yeah, that's perfectly fine. Let me just double. Oh, I have a 9 A.m. appointment. I do have an early morning appointment at a client's office.
He usually starts tomorrow at, he starts at 8 A.m. So anytime.
Okay.
Okay, so.
Yeah, we can we can do like an 830 A.m. meeting. That's fine.
8:30.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, I'm saying the invite, okay.
So me and Aman were talking about some things. So I just wanted to, I just want to show you like, this is an example. Like this was this week's deck. It actually wasn't on the, you know, we go over these slide decks every week that are assembled. This was just focused on ticket, focusing on tickets and what needs to be done.
Yeah, I was listening. I didn't interrupt.
The 4 rules that apply to every ticket, the customer note on every internal pairs with a customer facing note. I always stress this to my, to everybody, okay? You know, and a few weeks ago I said to Vincent, you need to communicate with customers. You can't just tell Shivani something and then she tells the customer something. If you're on the ticket and this is escalated to you, now you are working on that ticket.
Yep.
you're communicating, all resources are customer facing. So these are the decks that we go through and I can share all of my meetings with you. I can share these slide decks with you. Another deck from last week.
Is this one?
Okay, this is last week's deck.
And we reviewed, oh wait, no, that's not last week's thing. Sorry, this is last week's deck.
Kaila.
We continue to repeat the themes of divide and conquer, reunify and care, you know, ticket fundamentals, accountability, escalation, Samar's role, which she was new on the team. We talk about philosophical things, which ultimately will become, you know, the who and the how.
outcomes which will ultimately become...
roles and responsibilities for individuals. But we, you know, we really stress the tickets. Okay, so here you can see more rudimentary ticket, live ticket standards, you know, schedule and status, subject line, internal notes, discussion notes, one issue, one ticket, things like that.
Okay, that was last week. So let's see if I can pull up another meeting. So these meetings, again, I could share with you. We got to find a way to, again, like you said, you need to know.
That's right, yeah.
what we need to measure.
How will we measure it?
I do. I do. I do appreciate you. Yeah, go ahead.
Again, whatever, yeah.
Just a quick question. I'm really sorry to interrupt Alex. So the escalation process, right? Do we have a set time that they need to be escalating it to the next team within 15 minutes, 30 minutes, so that we are reiterating this to the team to make sure that escalation works as expected?
Yeah.
Yeah, no, no, there is there is no set time. OK, so, so, and this is the this is not I don't consider it a problem. I think I think part of the part of the challenge in this conversation is you don't have the context of everything that I've talked with Shivani about for six months, right? You don't have the context of.
Okay, okay.
everything I spoke with Vincent about over the past, you know, four months, five months. I expect a maturity in approach, okay? Humans are able to make decisions, okay? You know, if it's out of scope for Shivani, then she needs to escalate it. If Shivani can't solve a problem, she needs to escalate it.
If Vincent can't solve a problem, he needs to escalate it. We don't have a 15 minute deadline, but I'll tell you what, we have a customer satisfaction deadline. So, you know, everyone who works on every level needs to have an understanding of customer satisfaction. You know, if you...
if you don't have those senses about you, which I think everybody does. Every time I ask somebody, they understand whether a customer is, you know, if you just spend enough time on a particular issue, you know whether a customer is happy or unhappy. Shivani seems to sort of sometimes get out of touch with this, where
like on Monday, you know, we can't go back and forth for five hours for somebody to get remote access to a machine, right? With the user, right? You need to know how to handle that with the user to ensure that, you know, and or escalate it quickly, right? So either you got to escalate it fast or handle it with the user, but you can't have the user.
emailing back and forth with Shivani for five hours about something that she doesn't know about. So you just have to know whether as a tech, whether it's something you fully understand or not. Like today's meeting, I stressed the fact that
Number one, you need to document the problem correctly. Okay? Everybody, if there's a problem, you document the problem correctly. You determine how to replicate the issue, right? So then you know how to replicate the problem, and then you can isolate that problem. And then that is a triage process and an initial handling process.
So yeah, all the data, it should be all in the ticket very precisely, no matter who's working on it.
And then you can proceed to work on it, okay?
And then, when you, when you start working on it.
You know, um...
You know, if you fail at troubleshooting and you don't have a plan of action, okay, I think that's a very, obviously, that's a very common way of looking at things. So you say, okay, is there a plan of action status, right? That's, you know, also like ConnectWise, you could use SLAs to create that sort of plan of action.
you know, thing, workflow. We're not using all these workflows in ConnectWise, but it is common sense. If you don't have a plan of action, you have no idea how you're going to solve the problem 2 hours later and the customer's sitting there. Well, you know, I think it's obvious that somebody needs help, right?
So it becomes more and more obvious. Is it 15 minutes? No, it's not 15. It can't be, you know, is it 1/2 an hour? I guess it also depends, right? So I do not have a set rule that says, okay, Shivani, if you don't fix it in 15 minutes, escalate it. Because I want Shivani to develop, number one,
Sometimes if it's taking her a long time to work on something, but it doesn't impact the customer, that's also fine. You know, because it helps her learn. She can maybe spend a couple of hours on something that maybe I can fix in, you know, 5 minutes. But that's not the point because I don't want it to get escalated to me. I'm not here, right?
I also don't want to pull a more senior individual when they don't need to be pulled on to something necessarily. I don't know how to answer your question fully, you know, in a proper way. You know, I think that my meetings
No.
So.
you know, definitely speak for themselves, you know, and it's hard to take it out of context. And these guys have been part of it, but Aman has not, you know, and that's a challenge because anyway.
Oh yeah, no, not my line, Aleks. So maybe you can plan something and let me know, then we can work together and figure out a better way to kind of more centralized visibility for all the engineer, you know.
You know, so I'm most concerned that people understand why they do what they do, how they do what they do, you know, and then they out and what outcomes we're looking for, rather than, you know, micromanage their schedule. And, and I have, I want to have more trust and that's really the whole point, right? Like,
When Summer came on board, one of the things was, you know, the lack of trust or the lack of, you know, he was not able to do as many things as he's capable of doing at his old provider.
So, and we don't really have, I mean, Shivani's not supposed to be an L1, she's supposed to be an L2 or a rising L2 or, you know, L2 plus plus whatever, L1 plus plus like HSS plus, right? So she's not supposed to be, you know, I think she's also moved a little bit.
backwards in some of that, right? She hasn't, she's like, and I think maybe it's because she's moving, maybe she's, I don't know, you know, her mind might be somewhere else, but you know, I think she's taking a couple of steps, you know, I don't want to say that. Half of 1 step back, maybe, you know, like she's always,
I, you know, she's always responsive. I don't want to get on her case too much, but it's really the ticket handling, the customer communication, and the quality, the quality, not the quantity, is really the most important thing. I, you know.
Hello!
Yeah.
No, I get it, whatever point you mentioned.
We are, yeah, I agree. Aman, this is this is pretty solid messaging of what we have on screen, Alex, in the very first place. It will be helpful if we get a copy of the same, because once Aman is interacting with the team, like you mentioned, right, he can reiterate, I think.
reiterating the message over and over again would bring any sort of gaps that we currently see and make sure that team is aligned. Second thing that the good news that you may be really happy with is Shivani is currently in the process of shifting sites.
So currently she works out of our Chandigarh site where Sameer is based out of. And she's in the process of relocating to our Noida site where you have Sameer and the rest of the team as well, which means that she will be working very close to Aman and the rest of the team. So for Aman, it'll be much more easy to work very closely with Shivani.
And you know...
kill the gaps, anything that we currently see and anything which is low hanging fruit, these will be the quick wins that we can very easily address. So yeah, I mean, I guess, you know, give us a month or so, you will see the team settling in and you keep letting us know what are the gaps that you're finding in your side and Karen you can also let us know.
right, that anything and everything that you see on your site, so that we are calibrating the team and ensuring that they are constantly adjusting their best practices to fall in line with their expectations.
Great. Yeah, I will forward all of these decks to, and I try, and here's the other challenge. I try to keep it internal, you know, because I don't want to share my information. That's the challenge. I know that's why I don't just blast out the emails with my slide decks outside of my company, right? Because they're intended as confidential internal.
Yeah.
I know.
Mm.
Yeah.
Yeah, I know.
So, um...
Understood.
You know, and...
Not everything. Anything that you think out of the slides that you currently have, we can just extract where you think a work is needed, right? Or probably a couple of pointers where you think that we, that'll be helpful for us, that'll also do. Not necessarily the slide deck. All we need is, you know, anything that you've covered that needs to go as a messaging to the team.
As the reiteration, we can, we are more than happy to cover that as a part of our internal connect.
Yeah, that's good. We want, you know, we want to reiterate the same messaging. Yes, so that's so we're all on the same page. Now, I think that Shivani moving, I think that can be a good and a bad thing. I think it's overall, obviously, relatively good. But here's my only challenge, as Karen may have heard me say before.
When everybody's working in one office, sometimes the process falls apart because everyone's tapping each other on the shoulder instead of using the ticketing system to ensure that we're doing everything correctly, right? Assigning the, you know, the tech through the ticket, you know, and so the, you know, shoulder taps can be counterproductive sometimes, right? So I don't know how we balance that when everybody's working in one space.
That's why me and Amit here. I'm sitting in the front and Amit in the back.
Yes.
Ha ha ha.
Yeah, that we will take care of, Aleks. Leave it with us. So, yeah.
Yeah, because, because, you know, because I already have the problem where Shivani says, oh, Vincent's working on it. I'm like, well, how could Vincent be working on it if there was no ticket assignment done? You know, there was no, you know, no note in the ticket that assigned it to him. He's not even a resource on the ticket. So, and it wasn't communicated in the service delivery check.
You know, in the in Teams, so obviously, you know, she chatted with him directly and there was nothing done in the ConnectWise side, right? And that was just through Teams chat, right? So, you know, people are bypassing the procedures by just using Teams chat. Teams chat, you have to figure out as an as a person.
No, I get your point, yeah.
As an employee, you need to figure out how to do this, where you can chat with people in a ticket in Teams, but still do what you're supposed to do in ConnectWise, so that you know everybody stays aligned on everything, and it's very clear where something stands, you know, in a in a in a ticket.
Yeah.
And yeah, no, and stale, you know, stale tickets. I mean, we went through this whole exercise with BrightGage at the beginning of the year with Thomas, and it didn't help at all. Like, it literally didn't help at all. Nothing, you know, he was supposed to be looking at stale tickets, and I could see stale tickets, but the BrightGage dashboard that he built didn't have stale tickets, right?
I could just look at a board and I could say, oh, what's this, this, this. I could see all the past due appointments. It's very simple. Anybody can log in to ConnectWise who has the access, type in their name in the resource section, right?
Yeah, support the calendar and yeah, give you.
And you just simply see all of your own tickets, right? And you can see whether you have an appointment that's past due, right? Or if there's a future appointment on there. So it's extremely easy. We don't need to reinvent ConnectWise, right? ConnectWise is there. It's extremely easy. Karen can, I mean, Karen's not a tech, she can use it. She logs in.
And she immediately can see, hey, there's customers that are responding and nobody's responded to the tickets, right? So ConnectWise is built in a very normal way. I've used it for 20 years. If a customer responds to a ticket where that tech is assigned, that tech will get an email immediately, immediately.
Email.
And they should know immediately. They should have their Outlook on one screen somewhere. They would know immediately if the customer responded, right? If they're working on something else, that's fine. That's why I don't micromanage it, because they might be caught up with something else. But if I check two or three hours later, you know, that's when I get like, what? What is happening? Why is nobody, okay?
So these are the things, all right, these are the things that come up over and over as an issue. And it's, it hasn't really, you know, so that, the reason I bring it up is because it will come up again. So the sooner and the better we address it, the less we'll have to talk about it.
Yeah, I agree, likes, because whatever you sell is all fair, ask, right? Everyone follow that practice. When someone is working the ticket, it's a job to make sure they update the ticket on real-time basis, right? They put ticket on progress. That's what if an if I see an ADMIN point of view on a ConnectWise, I don't know what the other engineer doing, but...
Yeah, yeah.
From the board, I can see if the ticket is in progress, who is working. I can see the notes that give me the fair idea that what is the progress. It's not that I've started working on it, nothing on the connect wise, yeah, so it not the it will create a problem there, yeah.
You know, there was there was the access that you wanted Aman Aman to get into ConnectWise, which I still wanted to talk to you about at some point. You know, where where you're you know, you had your I guess you have an API and some stuff right that you do with other partners, right?
Yep.
Yeah, this way, yeah, right.
But tomorrow, I wanted to see if you can hop on a call with me. I sent you an invite. It's actually through this APMIT email address if you're able to join the call.
tomorrow. I'll resend it to you. We could talk about it a little bit later.
Yeah, yeah, definitely.
OK, alright guys, thank you, thank you for listening to all my gibberish.
Jessica.
Not at all.
Alex, I can tell you one thing, right? This is just an ideal conversation to have. And we don't get to hear such an ideal conversation all the time. So I'm really appreciative of how you see things, because this is how things should be. Right? So it is a difficult thing to achieve.
in today's world, I mean, I keep saying this to the new folks who joined, right, that you know, you don't know that we didn't have AI. You don't know that we didn't have smart tools. So when we were young and when we were walking through our tickets and everything, right, when we started learning how.
keen we were in terms of looking into every single detail and ensuring the tickets are done in the right way and working through the technology. So I think keeping this perspective in front of the team and then ensuring that it is moving in that direction, I think it ensures the team is healthy.
So yeah, we are completely aligned. It is nothing that, you know, you're over expecting things. I think it is a minimum expectation everyone should have. And of course, our responsibility is to keep working with the team to make sure that they are giving the best out of it. If anything is not working, I'm sure that, you know, we all can work together to make things work.
Yeah, that sounds lovely. Actually, I'll give you a thumbs up on that one.
Thank you.
Great, so I think we're good. We have a very good productive call, right? So hopefully tomorrow we have five people in our team. That's what I'm expecting. Yeah, thank you, Aleks. So thank you for all your time, Karen. Yeah, have a good day then.
Yeah.
Ha ha ha.
Okay, yes.
Thank you. Thank you, Karen.
Thank you. Bye.
Take care, bye-bye, bye.
Thank you very much. All right, bye-bye. Bye.
Cheers, bye.